fear is a killer to
the creative process and i've seen so
many people who are so talented get lost
in that area of doubt and uncertainty i
think it's a little bit like falling in
love you
you know you're cherishing
the love yeah and you don't want to pick
it apart yeah or you know there's a
mystery to why you love a person or why
you love a
story and yeah you have to try and build
muscles to hear that feedback
because um feedback is brutal it's like
you know every time you hear it you're
like oh i'm never gonna be good enough
you know it's help feedback is help
but um you know you can only take so
much time it's a really weird and kind
of like sour quality to the whole
process but it's so sweet and sour i
guess is the thing it's so important to
accept that sourness i love to look at
art books to be influenced in a not sort
of like photographic way but in a more
emotional way but you know for me like
it's so exciting to see a woman's voice
come out that actually
um not only introduces to the world but
to women you know that that they're
allowed to be rageful um would be angry
or to be you know to have ambivalent
feelings towards their best friend you
know from jealousy to
envy anger love adoring you know
we're going to do the same thing we
always do we're going to put the camera
up we're going to put some people in
front of it
and we're going to shoot it
[Music]
it's all about like the inspiration
being so strong that you can
carry you through the stresses that
you're going to have to encounter to get
it done
um and
for me
um
when the inspiration's quite weak you
have a lot more fear
and
i always think that it's to do with like
getting the right
um
proportion of inspiration to fear and
you've just got to have two percent more
inspiration than fear
and if you can get that then you can go
but
fear is a killer to
the creative process and i've seen so
many people who are so talented
um get lost in that area of doubt and
uncertainty
which fair breeds
so
it's really important to
love what you
the source material or the whatever the
the inspiration is very much so that you
feel
um this
just love
this one interesting choice i was gonna
ask you about this voiceover that we
only hear at the beginning and then it
sort of drops out like
why have that only in the beginning
well
i wanted to steer the um people's
attention towards peter because we see
him only very briefly
um
at the beginning of the film
and um
then he's off at school before he comes
back but i want them to know
right that so you know in the back of
their brain somewhere if it works i
think i think most people can't remember
what was said but i tried to keep it i
had one more complicated version of it
which i think had a lot of um
great texture but you couldn't remember
it at all but i think he's basically
just saying you know
you got to help your mother yeah
and um
that that might just trigger a memory
later and just to know this isn't you
know this isn't just going to be a story
about um two brothers that are not
getting on anymore you know
experience i didn't know
myself for a long time
how
deep this um story goes for me but
actually had an evil nanny
that was
who was like from the age of five to the
age of about 11. my sister and i had to
deal with her and she was um
real [ __ ]
and she was a disturbed person and she
would
like separate us from our parents and
you know not let us nail them and we
were told we never allowed to say
anything about her and
and also she would get violent and she
actually whipped me once you know wow
with a horse whip
so in a way i
understood that um yeah i realized oh i
know phil
well
i really know phil i mean you know from
the other side and you know i remember
always knowing where she was in the
house you know
like i wouldn't i would think oh she's
up on that virgin okay so i can be okay
here oh that's so interesting yeah and
so it was actually really haunting and
you know she actually died
um
from some disease she was very tragic
and horrible but we didn't care we were
so happy she was dead
and that's why i'm so weird and
difficult
because it definitely feels like you're
in touch with
the dark side in a good way but it's
funny how you didn't i didn't see that
until later yeah yeah i feel like but
there's an attraction to it because you
somehow know you know
yeah do you feel like with projects
you're attracted to them and then later
you see why you were well or do you try
to understand that i didn't get it until
later yeah i mean not it was before i
was filming but
um it took me a while to get my actual
personal connection with someone a
little bit like oh no this is a good
story yeah yeah i totally like that i
don't i don't unders i try not to
understand why i'm into something and
just follow that and then after i'm like
oh that's be and then i understand it
later
i think it's a little bit like falling
in love you
you know you're cherishing the
the love yeah and you don't want to pick
it apart yeah or you know there's a
mystery to why you love a person or why
you love a
story and yeah
i give everything i have to each of them
as i go and
some of them land in the world better
than others
um and
you know once they've landed in the
world i sort of step back and lead them
to it you know
but while i'm making them i give them
every
you know all the love and attention and
any sort of
intelligence i can offer it to do the
best job with it
but
as i say they do land really differently
and i think some of that
exploration of you know till you can
find out how to you know do it really
well
is is is what the learning is about
which is really just about you know like
i learned that you know your friends can
tell you you just say be very brutal
tell me what you like what you don't
like and and you have to try and build
muscles to hear that feedback
because um feedback is brutal it's like
you know every time you hear it you're
like oh i'm never going to be good
enough you know
but
you you can have that attitude of like
um
is i mean they it's help feedback is
help
but um you know you can only take so
much time it's a it's a really difficult
thing you know you need the truth but i
mean it's like you need
inspiration to do really well and you
need
um you know to learn
and and there's a little bit of fear and
pain
involved in that
but you've got to have the people that
love you and support you and a little
bit like seeing you into a future that
you're not quite yet there yet with you
know like someone having someone that
that love is so important to this
process yet you still
have to have the um determination to do
better to do better to do better to fix
it you know it's quite a
it's just it's just
it's a really weird and kind of like
sour quality to the whole process but
it's so sweet and sour i guess is the
thing it's so important to accept that
sourness
and um i think you know habit is part of
the process it's just it you know i
don't know many filmmakers that are
carried away by themselves because they
just know how many times they've failed
you know in whatever project they're
doing they fixed it they fixed it they
fixed it they fixed it they fixed it and
and
you know so i you know i've learned to
be you know a great failure
your portraiture of men
is so
acute and
every time i see your movies i'm i'm
very affected by it
and one way or another i find it
really precise but really
compassionate and brutal at the same
time
meaning it's unsparing and this one the
composition of the character of benedict
i could not imagine before seeing the
movie him doing that part
but you did so how did you choose it
well i think one of the excitements is
having an actor that you can't imagine
coming to the performance that they do i
mean the calculation that i made was
that benedict is an amazing actor he
certainly is and he's very charismatic
man and intelligent and he had the
hunger and
i was also sort of had this instinct
that you know we had to do some psyche
work together
something
that went further than normal i just
sort of asked around and found out about
this woman called kim gillingham
who
does dream work and she's trained by
sandra c cat and marion woodman
who's a really amazing canadian jungian
therapist because i really felt
my three favorite words canadian
therapist i meant we had to build him
from the psyche up and i also needed to
be opened up to the depths of the story
like i was sort of sitting on the edge
of this amazing novel
you know thomas savage who lived the
life and thinking oh my god how am i
going to
get inside you know be inside it and and
we did it through our dreams
both of us
what do you mean like you you you
analyze your dreams and i had the dreams
i wrote them down i met with her and she
sort of
got me to lie down soothing music and
everything
and then she started you know with the
script
to
facilitate almost a discussion between
mice
myself as phil
and jane the director
wow
she said jane you're phil now and she
said so as phil what would you want to
tell jane about what she needs to know
to tell your story wow
and immediately i said you know like i
was so harsh i was so tough
saying to you know the jane the director
you know well that [ __ ] has got to get
real
she's got to take off that little white
scientific code of hers wow and get
dirty just get in the dirt hole because
that's the truth you know yes and i know
and i was going
wow
yes i do yeah i mean so it was really
just facilitating the conversation
clearly
um that would be very hard to do alone
between myself and an imagined character
the first couple of films also really
sort of define
the subject space i think in such an
interesting way they're about women who
are outsiders who have difficult
relationships with convention like they
don't behave the way they're expected to
behave fortunately yeah exactly but were
you were you really aware like this
these women don't exist in cinema and i
really want to tell their stories i
think i didn't really think of it like
that i just thought like
i'm always attracted to you know
bad girls
of
[Music]
literature as well you know like if you
even if you think of um emily bronte
emily
bronte was unsociable she's incredibly
unsociable she wouldn't go out and yet
here she is writing
i think one of the sexiest man i mean
she's undoubtedly a virgin you know
we've got emily dickinson who
who was the social outcast
who lived and worked in her room and
lived a life of literature and for me a
lot of these women shunned
the world for a good reason as the world
was not welcoming to them
and um yeah they think that they
created their own through their
imagination they're
you know a preferable world but you know
for me like it's so exciting to see a
woman's voice come out that actually
um not only introduces to the world but
to women you know that they're
that they're allowed to be rageful
um would be angry or to be you know to
have ambivalent feelings towards their
best friend
you know from jealousy to um envy anger
love adoring you know
and um
because i i think even
that you know like for a long time you
know
the patriarch has ruled um some arch
staff that
and they have a very particular vision
of how women
how they want to see women
which is
[Music]
either the
um you know like the mother type that
does everything for everyone and
everywhere or the
the the no little cute
innocent
and you know this is not a prescription
for a life
um the understanding of who really women
are in the world through cinema you know
is kind of curated through men
it's not to say that there aren't some
really sensitive great
men but they you know maybe
there are a lot of sensitive great women
too
um sweetie itself
um
was
a sort of story
um of written by myself and my
ex-boyfriend at the time gerard lee who
i've done a lot of writing with since
and um
yeah we just sort of
wrote about
in disguise ourselves and our family
and
i mean it's also fictionalized
um
but jared did have a
um
schizophrenic brother who was deaf and
really chaotic in the family that
caused so many dramas and problems and
um
so he was a little bit and he was also
like a wonderful character but he was
also you know a lot of the inspiration
for sweetie who we changed to
a girl and played by genevieve lemon so
amazingly what was it about this story
power of the dog that brought you back
to film after 12 years
i think that it just existed on so many
really interesting levels and that it's
a kind of
full of secrets
and the secrets that get resolved and
there's a secret that you don't see
coming which is the murder mystery
and then you have to think your way
right back through the story to figure
out how you missed it how it happened i
mean i feel like i maybe don't compare
to the level you do but i do prepare
similarly yeah i'm still terrified when
i get on to the set you know i've gone
like i've freaking tried to prepare i've
tried to do everything and i still don't
feel i know
what to do at all
what to do at all and it's not till i'm
like i'm driving there with my first
assistant and i'm saying i don't know
what to do
i don't know how to do this i've
forgotten how to film i've forgotten how
to film i don't know what to do and he
said jane
we're going to do the same thing we
always do yeah we're going to put the
camera up we're going to put some people
in front of it
and we're going to shoot it yeah yeah
okay
and as soon as that camera gets up
i suddenly you know an almond or
whatever an activated arm and i go all
right
you